my sake is no stranger to violence
although it's usually left to the
professionals in the rink I don't know
what's burning can you tell what's
burning
but for Vancouver Canucks fans seeing
their team crash in the Stanley Cup
final became all too much
mobs vented their fury on the streets of
the Canadian City some clearly fueled by
booze they rampaged at will stretching
the police operation the violence was
concentrated in the city centre ferocity
seemed to take the authorities by
surprise you can see the police
advancing up Homer right now this is
really the first time we've seen them
try to gain a foothold I haven't seen
tear gas or anything like that yet you
still see a number of those police
officers although some are in riot gear
many of them are not only goes for the
Boston Bruins set up a four nil win in
this the seventh under siding games
the Canadians were the favourites to
secure the Stanley Cup the competition
they haven't won since and from the
league 14 years ago they'd made the
finals back in 1994 and they lost then
also resulted in rioting we did so much
to bring this city to read history
police say the riots were started by a
small section of supporters and many of
the other fans were simply bystanders an
investigation is now underway with some
blaming the city's relaxed police
tactics Martius Joshi Sky News